did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
on TV on Radio and on your smartphone
this is talk
TV tonight on Pi Morgan uncensor I've
come to a place that's been on my bucket
list of places to visit uh in my time in
America and it's this extraordinary car
imporium that belongs to the TV
Superstar Jay Leno one of the world's
greatest ever talk show hosts but also a
car fanatic he has got over 200 of the
greatest cars ever made including the
most expensive car in history and
tonight he's going to sit down with me
for an exclusive interview about life
about America about the upcoming
elections but also about his cars
because behind every car is an
incredible
[Music]
story Jay I've got to say I've lived and
worked in Los Angeles for nearly 20
years my number one bucket
list of the whole time I've been here
has been to get inside your well it's
not like I didn't invite you I invited
you dozens of time so it's not like
you're like oh no I don't want to want
come oh yeah yeah okay but well well
thanks for I got to say you walk in
we're going to go on a little walk and
talk with your cars later but but just
to walk into this is a quite
extraordinary thing I have never seen a
car collection like this anywhere in the
world well there's plenty of car
collections like I just buy what I like
it's the more money than brains Club
there's really no theme here it's not
Italian cars or the Renaissance you know
it's none of that it's just just things
I like cause of historical or technical
interest and you know it's fun you know
when you work with your hands and
appreciates how easy it is to make money
just talking you know because you take a
transmission like ah some guy made 80
bucks for this and then you go on say oh
plus I think it it it makes you
appreciate Show Business
Jay Leno is the tonight's show King who
ruled late night in America for over 20
years reaching the blue collar parts of
Middle America is competitors couldn't
Leno's rivalry with the great David lman
is the stuff of Show's Legend as is the
story of how he came out of retirement
to reclaim his show from his successor
Conan O'Brien Lennon's interviewed the
biggest names of our times giving him a
unique perspective of what makes the
great country of America tick including
what unites it and what divides it when
you look at the state of politics in
America particularly fueled perhaps by
social media which tends to inflame the
extremities on both sides do you worry
about that do you worry that America's
becoming ever more polarized politically
being an
optimist my the biggest fear for years
was not enough nobody's voting and
nobody voted this last election whether
you for Trump or for Biden hug huge
everybody go not everybody but the
highest no one ever predicted that they
thought it would just continue to go
down and people under 30 would never
vote and you know well no that all
changed so it it got people interested
so I think that's one of the benefits of
it you know what do you make of the
Donald Trump phenomena there's there
other way to describe it when in 1999 he
appeared on the tonight's show with you
right uh and was when he first said he
was going to run for president and you
like everybody else laughed at this
concept and you quized him about his
temperament and Trump said this to you I
believe when someone wants to get you
you want to get them and I believe that
and you said but being president you'd
have to be more diplomatic and he
replied yes but I believe in
retribution well a no one's laughing now
because he became president May well be
again and he does exact retribution he's
done exactly what he said he would do
what do you think of this phenomenon of
trump the politician I'm not a fan uh I
think he has liked his thing but they
want to restrict him on the ballot I I'm
against that because that can turn
against you you could use it for
whatever it's anti-democratic right it's
anti-democratic I mean if the people
want that person as presid that's fine I
mean I'm not a fan has nothing to do
with politics I I just don't think
morally I think do a little bit better
all these indictments whatever it might
be you know I just stopped doing
politics in my act altoe because you
know when I did The Tonight Show the
idea was you made fun of both sides
equally and you get those miss you and
your Republican well misso you and your
Democratic buddies you know and they'd
both be angry and I go oh that's good
you know they both think you're
supporting the other guy now you've got
to take a sign and people are angry if
you don't and I find what I would start
to tell a political joke they want to
know the punchline before is this Pro or
against you know so I just I just
stopped doing it because I I just want
people to come and laugh and have a good
time I mean I've known Trump a long time
I did the Celebrity Apprentice with him
I saw him a lot every night across the
border and I saw actually a different
character there than one I see as a
politician but you know he was always
bombastic Larger than Life always a big
exaggerator narcissist and so on which
is fine if you're not President right
yeah I was going to ask you that when
you were interviewing him as Donald
Trump the real estate magnet come
television celebrity what did you think
of him then well I liked him he was fine
he was an interesting character he was a
television character exactly what you
wanted for TV you know somebody that
that kind of irritates some people and
uses other and that's fine I I I I liked
them then I actually did a couple of
jobs for as that I just you know this
January 6 business and all this other
thing that's gets a little much well I
mean I would imagine most Americans who
don't have a kind of really
visceral horse in the ring in this and
look at it objectively the idea of any
president from either side simply
refusing to accept the result of an
election in America yeah that's a pretty
slippery path yeah yeah that's a very
slippery path it's to me it's like uh I
like my banker to be about finances I
don't want a funny Banker I don't want a
banker who's a flashy dresser with
Italian sports cars and I I like her to
be a banker and that's what I wanted to
present I mean to
me I see nothing about the economy or
about what's going to be done for the
country it's just getting back at
Hillary or whatever it just seems to be
uh
things you shouldn't be worrying about
as president when you look at Joe Biden
he's 10 years older than you yeah I mean
most people including the majority of
Democrats think he's too old to run
again do you think he should maybe take
one for the team and step aside well I
think he's fine to be president I think
it's harder to run for president than it
is to be you got to go to the fair and
eat the hot dog and you know through the
whole all of that uh which I mean I
don't know I mean it's uh look I I'm a
fan I like the man I've known him for
years I had him on when he ran in 88 you
know so uh to me uh no I like him I
think he's a good guy and you know the
economy is doing pretty good right I
mean that's something Trump said he
hopes the economy tanks I sold that well
I really do you really hope that's when
I knew we were in trouble when I would
talk I meet people on the street I'd
rather have Putin than Biden really
really do you worry about what may
happen in this country in terms of the
division if Trump was to get reelected
well you get the government you deserve
I mean that's pretty much the way the
world works or at least the way America
works if that's what people choose well
that's that's what's going to happen
isn't it what does it mean to you to be
an American well it just it it makes me
laugh because it's the only place like
said we don't want I don't want an
experienced politician in the White
House do you feel America's still the
land of opportunity just still yes you
know if you want to appreciate America
this is why I love immigrants you know
well America is the ultimate melting it
really doesn't seem to be I don't see
people oh we're trying to get into
Moscow we don't can't I nobody wants to
go there would it would it been a better
country if if the British Royals had
continued to oversee things oh that
would been horrible would terrible thing
that would have been no horrible
horrible you don't sometimes think
wistfully you could have been you know
Prince Jay and yeah that's what I want
to do Prince J my mother from Scotland
I'm mother from well I was gonna say I
mean the similarity you have with Donald
Trump is you both had mothers who were
Scottish you came out here and both your
fathers were salesmen in New York right
yeah that's true that's true is that
where the parallels stop I think that's
what parall stop I again I just don't
agree with some of the moral decisions
and other things you know you think one
of one of the secrets of his success
because you can't deny the success or
the popularity is he does have well is
it success or popularity I mean what are
you talking about well success in the
sense he won the presidency with zero
experience I mean that's pretty
extraordinary right uh in popularity he
got 10 million votes more last election
than the first time around which is
pretty staggering given how divisive his
tenure was and he may well win again the
poll suggest he's got a very good chance
I think you have to have the ability
to I don't dislike people who like Trump
I mean I meet people all the time you
know guys that are uh mechanics or like
bluecollar guys that like Trump for that
reason and I like them I like them I
don't you know we live in an era now if
you have an electric car you're a vegan
and you voted for Biden and you want
Governor Nome to be president of the
United States if you have a gas car you
like guns you like you know the idea
that you you you've got to be one or the
other to me I I have I like to have
friends on
both sides it is that one of the reasons
that there's a a sense that far less is
being actually done in the senate in
Congress because it's so visceral now
the tribalism on both sides very
difficult for politicians to do deals
with the other side I think so and if
and if you do you're a traitor or
whatever it might be you know I I mean
you know I like Mitt Romney I think he's
a terrific guy um great human being uh
uh the fact that he gets
ostracized from the Republican party
because of his views is nuts but I I
think he's I think he's correct I I mean
I I don't want a president who's been uh
impeached two times it just
seems I think we can do better do you
think anyone should be allowed to run
for president on on any side if you're
facing a 100 criminal charges well I
have the right not to vote for them so I
would I would here's my vote if you
choose to have someone who's a criminal
as president okay I have to accept your
choice what do you make of the the woke
culture particularly where it pertains
to cancel culture I always meet
comedians that say uh you know you can't
even compliment women anymore well yeah
you can't go hey nice boobs okay if you
were to say oh that's a really pretty
dress I don't when
go actually there are some that would
now take no but see but I think you're
objectify what I'm saying is I said oh
it's a nice outfit oh thank you I mean
I'm I'm using normal people common sense
not one extreme or the other most people
know when youve crossed the line did did
the me too campaign go too far is the
pendulum coming back well no I think any
any pendulum swings to the far left to
the far right before it comes back to
center it's just something that happens
I
mean yeah no I I I think it is what it
is and I think you're seeing you come
back to center now okay I think there's
a lot of anger a lot of animosity uh
women over the years have built up um
you know if if you were someone this
happened to you in the 60s 70s and 80s
you're going to be pretty mad in the 90s
and the 2000s so I I get it I I
understand it and is it unfair that it
swings that way yeah but it was unfair
it went the other way too so you
interviewed a lot of people who were Mew
mhm were was that a surprise to you when
you found out what some of them were
actually
like well for a lot of them you kind of
knew they were like that I mean there's
not a lot of people where I go oh really
I'm surprised that you
know Harvey Weinstein I
mean he was always a bully he was a
bully he would call me and say I I I
need so and so on the show tomorrow
night and I go I can't I got so well get
kick them off I go hry I'm not going to
do it and he would yell at me and
intimidate where you're not going to get
any you know he would just be that way
all the and he was a bullet so when when
he got caught I was not the least bit
surprised we're here thanks for joining
us you're with talk TV on TV on radio
online and on your smart speaking
criminals to using XL Bully dogs as
weapons to threaten others no matter how
well Tred most dog owners will tell you
a dog can turn you know what I love
about to today we do it all sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other s star is about to help make
children even taller
now go that's what's going to happen if
you vote
labor Long Live JK Rowling and her right
to stand up for women we can only pity
those who despise their straightforward
Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million 140
million pounds so far so 140 million
pounds so far result nil absolutely nil
Kevin O Sullivan is the worst presenter
on talk TV sitting on his
fat like brought to you by Steve KH the
mayor of London bought us with our own
money the the mayor's fireworks very
rarely meet anybody that says you know
the thing about London is he got a great
mayor sque K brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film
stop creating all of these funny little
factions with their funny little names
the new conservatives the ERG the common
sense research group the red wool red
trouser popcorn I mean popcorn what what
is that I just cannot see if richy suak
goes does what David Frost what Lord
Frost wants him to do and go further to
the right on taxes and immigration that
that would turn around the what's
predicted by this poll in a landslide
Donald Trump didn't just win he
obliterated this is a guy facing fa ing
nearly a 100 criminal charges and yet
all that's done is actually make him
more popular Trump is canny enough to
know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you or that's the way up did my 6 months
I came back nobody would touch me I put
my head down and persisted and carried
on when I say I am God I'm not joking
did you feel Elvis was controlling I've
been answering your question you answer
mine it's actually not my job to answer
your questions I've asked you two
questions should a mass stay in power
and are they a terror group you're
refusing to answer either of them that
is very telling talk TV it's the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
[Music]
that
I appeared on the tonight's show uh
several times when you were the host
absolutely loved it and what struck me
about the whole kind of Mythology around
you the tonight's show your Rivals and
so on was a narrative began to build
that you were some kind of Ruthless
monster when my personal experience of
you we didn't know each other certainly
the first time was you couldn't have
been more friendly gracious normal non-
monstrous in fact you the complete
opposite uh one of the nicest people
genuinely I'd met in the business what
did you feel when that became this sort
of thing about you that people were
saying this stuff well like I always
say if you're playing football who do
you tackle you tackle a guy with the
ball it's as simple as that you know my
attitude is I don't believe the good
stuff and I don't believe the bad stuff
like you well thank you oh that's very
kind guys I didn't like you Mon oh okay
well I'm sorry nice to are you were very
funny oh thank you I'm not that funny
but okay thank you you know so I mean to
me that's sort of where I am um I mean
that's what kind of happens in The
Tonight Show when you look back on that
whole period particularly when it all
went sour for almost everybody involved
right so you know lman Conan you and
everything when you look back on it it
was clearly a febrile kind of period do
you have any regrets about it no I don't
I I don't regret any of it I was fine no
was fine I enjoyed it I loved it I mean
actually the favorite part of my my
career is when I was doing Letterman in
the 80s cuz I'd put together like I
would go on once a month and have a six
or eight minute piece and try it out on
Dave when we started here's we sort of
met at the comedy store
Dave was sort of a nervous performer but
a great Wordsmith I mean you could weave
words together in exactly the
phraseology where the joke was in the
phraseology as opposed to the punchline
you know uh I was kind of loud and
verbose and do different voices and
things like that and David go well how
can you be so loose on stage I said man
I love the way you weave sentences
together and I think we sort of
complimented each other L McCarney huh
well yeah maybe maybe arold
Schwarzenegger and sliced alone they
they hang out together having been
tremendous Rivals they now hang out
together most weeks if they're in town
they get a cafe roer and they just chew
the fat together and they get a lot out
of that it's almost like after the war
right sort of like the way with Seinfeld
when Seinfeld and I get together and
talk we each Come Away with something
some piece of material some little
nugget of something that we can use you
know uh because he is one of the great
comics and to to me he likes the
technical aspect of writing jokes you
know and letman was the same way too
very clever very sharp you know uh good
ad Liber no I I I I'm hugely a fan of
Dave you know I was real happy because I
would get the ratings and he would get
the critics and that was fine with me or
I could have switched that at any point
I'll take critics or well you take great
all right fine I mean it it it it didn't
matter I like the fact we both were
successful and we both came away with
with uh with some what about Conan ABB I
like Conan I you know that that's
another one of those weird
situations that when he was at
NBC Don was not a fan and he said I I
like this guy at the third you know he
asked me what I thought I said I like
him I think he's really funny I said I
tell you what I'll promote him every
night at the end of my show hey stay t
for Conan he's got uh you know Sean
Conor whatever it might be so we did
that every night and that was fine and
then uh after quite a few years um Jeff
Zucker came to me and said uh K people
want you out he wants the show I go what
are we do well here here's my favorite
thing I said well I'm number one and I
remember one of the NBC Executives said
you know we want what's above number
one I said that he so la yeah and I said
well what what is that well we just want
I said be better than number one J and
to me I always signed pay and play
contracts I never signed you know I say
people I got a development deal they
have to pay me even if I don't work and
I go okay you don't want that because if
they're paying you not to work that
means they don't want you to work
they're paying you not to work I so my
deals are always if you're paying me you
gotta so my contract was pretty I'm on
for five years okay at the end of five
years they want to replace you with
Conan and I said I didn't have a manager
I didn't have an agent I didn't have any
really did it yourself no I do it myself
I said look if they don't want
you I don't want to die of a thousand
paper cuts you know what I'm saying so I
said okay fine so I Tire after the next
five years Conan's doing fine and then
Craig Ferguson comes along who was great
and Craig Ferguson goes out con and then
suddenly he starts winning he wins a py
award and other things and every
nominated and they go and then suddenly
Jeff stooker and everybody's like oh we
make a mistake I said guys I'm here I'm
what am I doing I said well uh i' been
trying to figure out what to do they
said you wanted you want to stay on I
what am I going to stay on as so they
said we'll do a 10:00 show I never
thought a 10:00 show would work but they
said I'll tell you we'll pay your staff
for 2 years full benefits pay all right
we'll try it well it lasted about nine
months because we're competing with Law
and Order and 10:00 drama series and
stuff it didn't work uh and then they
said well how if you go on at 11:30 for
half an hour and Conan takes it from 12
I said if Conan will go for that I'll go
for it but well they brought that to con
he said no and he quit so then they came
to me and said I want you come back I
said all right fine but there was no
isn't the truth really I mean I read it
all and isn't the truth in the end you
didn't want to leave the tonight's show
in the first place you were number one I
didn't want to leave you didn't want to
leave you were put in a position where
you kind of were forced to and
everything else unraveled from that
you've still been blamed by certain
number of people about it all but it
seemed to me that your only crime was
that you were number one in a show you
love doing right right and you didn't
want to give it up yeah that's pretty
much it I mean that was the story wasn't
it that was the story yeah but I mean
the idea that I would read these things
that L demanded $150 million no I said
how they fired me how could I demand you
know they they have all these ridiculous
things and isn't it true that you you
never used any of your money from
television no
nothing I'm a comedian I make my living
doing stand-up comedy if you get a TV
show H it's nice but TV shows last
either 6 weeks or 22 years what did you
do with these hundreds of millions of
dollars
still there untouched well I mean not
untouched but yeah yeah I I live pretty
with the exception of cars and
motorcycles about to say you live
frugally surrounded by the greatest car
I'm still using the happy me coupons you
know I mean it's funny because I'm one
of those people I live on what I I make
that week if I don't work this week I
think I'm broke is that is that going
back to the early days of Comedy oh yeah
yeah all comedians seem to have that
streak in them they're terrif that one
day they'll be back you always you have
to be hungry you have are you still as
hungry as ever yes really yes just
amazing yeah after all your success
everything you've achieved yeah you
still have that burning inside you well
I I mean I like to write jokes and tell
them you like to try them out I mean so
the same joke you do over here at
Flappers of the comedy magic
club you same when you get paid tons of
money in Vegas think you could still be
doing the tonight's show I mean if if
everything had just been left as it was
well I think at some point you realize I
shouldn't have to know all of jayc's
music you know what I mean I knew I was
it was going while AG go l g my next
guest is soulmore albums and Elvis and
The Beatles combined please welcome who
is this who is this guy I never heard of
the song I don't know him I'm meeting
him for the first time what I mean then
I realized okay maybe it's getting a
little you know I had two moments on The
Tonight Show with you which I I will
never forget one you know about because
you said it to me the other one you
don't know about I think but
the first one was when I was at CNN and
I was taking on the NRA about the the
gun the mass shootings after Sandy Hook
and it was getting very unpleasant the
whole debate and you came and saw me in
my dressing room for a cup of tea and
you said look here's the deal
Pi the problem is he said that you're
preaching to an audience most of whom
probably have guns or like guns it's a
bit like if you went to Germany and told
them to to stop speeding on the autobar
right they don't want to hear it from
you and they definitely don't want to
hear it from your accent and I thought
it was a brilliant advice it really made
me stop and think that actually it's
it's American culture and for somebody
from Britain to come in and start
lecturing Americans about right their
culture there are clear issues with the
gun violence in this country which need
to be sorted but Americans need to sort
that themselves right it can't be down
to you know somebody like Mad King
Charles's Mad King got me like somebody
like Mad King George is Success right
right right yeah but I remember you
doing that and I was very grateful
because it put it into clear sense for
me um and the other thing you probably
don't know I did the show Once with
Robin Williams we were the only two
guests and I was in my dressing room and
it was just when Susan Bole had become
the biggest breakout reality talent show
star in history with I dreamed a dream
and I was in the dressing with my late
great manager John and we were sitting
there and the door knocked and in came
Robin Williams but he was in character
he was half Susan Bole half Mrs
Doubtfire that's funny and he did a
15minute turn just in impromptu it was
one of the funniest things I've ever
watched in my life and it was just for
me and my manager and then he went and
that was it and we were on stage we did
our bit with you and that was it and we
went our separate ways I never saw him
again but it was an INT uction to Real
Genius oh yeah he was Willam he's
fabulous you know I first met him he was
posing as a Russian comedian and I was
telling people this kid he's funny but
he speaks Russian he's not really you
know I I didn't realize it was
Rob we're here thanks for joining us you
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well you know what
I love about talk today we do it all
sunak sella
scon I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the tor's love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the other
the police are pro Palestine that is
just not right you swearing off in the
police to act without fear or favor the
co inquiry seems to have turned into a
sort of pantomim there's not really any
to it's hard to know whether it's a f or
a tragedy there needs to be one human
per machine to come and rectify beeps
and the clanks and when it goes roll
unexpected item in bagging area I know
are we only going to be trusting sources
like meta and Google where is our
unbiased news going to come from Gram
was president of the Cambridge unit
which is the rubbish version of being
president of the Oxford
unit Kevin O Sullivan is the worst
presenter on talk TV sitting on his fat
ass talking living if you're walking
towards me and you're a vegan you have a
great big orange sticker over here
saying watch out vegan's about Twitter
you sons of can you please reinstate my
account thank you this is a major Summit
President Biden decided this is
important after watching a Tom Cruz
film kids think all they have to do is
take pictures of everything just shut
down Tik Tok problem solve when I say I
am God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was trolling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your question are
you prepared to call H A terou is it
possible to have a
rational talk TV is the only place where
you get the
truth this is talk
[Music]
TV
when you see people like Dave Chappelle
literally being attacked on stage for
their comedy does that worry you that
that that line has been crossed now
where people you when you saw what
happened with Will Smith just makes well
it makes me laugh cuz I used to work at
a place called the Rodeo Lounge that had
chicken wire so it' be on stage telling
Jes boom a bottle would just bounce off
the outside of it and smash on the
ground so people throwing so the idea
that you're quite used to all this no
the idea of being attacked on stage oh
that's fine yeah that's compared to
people throwing bottles and that was
actually okay yeah when you saw Will
Smith slap Chris Rock at the Oscars what
went through your mind watching that
well what went through my mind is
somebody totally misreading a situation
I think you're sitting there and
someone's insulting your wife and go bet
if I go up and I SM I bet people go yeah
look you know John wils Booth the exact
same thing John wil's Booth the actor
who shot Abraham Lincoln hugely popular
and hated Lincoln and the South hated
Lincoln e well I'm going to get up there
I'm going to kill Lincoln and I will be
a bigger star than and that's that that
was his motivation that he would make
him more famous and more powerful well
that backfired pretty quick but are you
comparing Will Smith to the worst the
most assassin in American history no not
not that but it's just the idea that you
know you've got this thing going okay
guy insult some under up there I'm going
to I'm going to slap him for some cuz
it's not I don't think it's far-fetched
to think that some people would see that
as hey that's a real man or women go I
wish my husband would do that when that
guy in a bar insulted me you know so
that's what I like to think probably
went through his mind he just misread
the
situation uh but who knows I watched The
Golden Gloves Joe Koy who I'd never
heard of but he was this standup guy
very nice guy very funny guy right
incredibly unfunny presenting the Golden
Globes I mean was like cring making to
watch well that's a tough crowd that's
you can still tell funny jokes
well not when you have just a few days
to prepare I mean he took the job at the
last minute if I was an agent if I gave
you 10 minutes notice to do the Globes I
wouldn't do it you still make people
laugh you could Wing your way through it
no no because that's a totally that is a
crowd you know you can't have you done
any of those award shows no I always I
always I got asked to host Oscars a
couple times I said look I say look I
tell jokes every night on The Tonight
Show do I save my best jokes for The
Tonight Show I go do my best jokes on
the Oscars but during the nobody wants
to see me do jokes five nights a week or
and then the six night oh I come out and
they tell jokes again you just saw me
Friday night so you're sympathy of a
jokoy yes I do because I know he's funny
and it's just not well I can remember
one big star I had oh I it was Walk
Phoenix he he was on the show and he was
in character when he had the beard and
just sort of mumbling about character at
the end of the show I said uh hey thanks
for coming here next time I hope you can
come in person you know so his publicist
D he is a genius you don't talk to him
that way I go he wasn't a genius tonight
he was kind of rude and really wasn't
that funny you know and he it wasn't
that interesting you know I mean I guess
he's a nice guy but he was just being
very you know if you don't want to be
there fine don't don't be there you know
you know that was a great thing about
doing The Tonight Show I could be in
Show Business without being in Show
Business who are your favorite guests
when you look back at it Rodney was a
favorite one so while he's doing his act
I I said to debie our producer I said I
think Rodney's having a stroke would you
call paramedic she goes really I go no I
think he is okay then the show ends
Rodney his dressing room by this time
the paramedics came in and I I go Rodney
can the paramedics t look at it I think
maybe had a stroke he goes I'm okay I'm
okay well he did have a stroke really
and they took him out in the stretcher
and he passed away not long after that
wow but another great guest was um I
love Shan connory yeah cuz he was not
James Bond whenever Shan connory come to
the show he go J J what's the latest
filthy joke going about you you know so
I would tell him the joke and he would
laugh like a
pirate he would laugh like he would
literally slap his knee go oh my God a
funny one and he was the only one who
would take a shower in those little
dressing rooms and he would sing Oh
Scotland he just sing Scottish songs you
know and the news crew out what trying
to do the news I said Sean Conor sh in
the shower so he just all he was the
only star I ever heard my mother go you
know that's a real man jimie I go M I
don't want you to talk like no jimie
that's a real man that Shan com you also
had the six most famous words probably
in talk show history when you looked at
Hugh Grant after his little indiscretion
in Los Angeles with oh what were you
thinking what the hell were you thinking
yeah that was just an ad lib but it did
you think about that before did come out
no I just asked him and you know he was
great because in those days I'm sure he
had a publicist but he came by himself I
went in the dressing room I said look I
got to ask you about this you can answer
I'm not going to contradict you or or
belabor the point but I just have to ask
she goes that's okay I deserve it you
know he he was very funny and he was
very nice you know nowadays everybody
has crisis man te and all kind ofs but
no he he was really terrific but I'll
tell you one that was really interesting
to me uh I
was 13 when John F Kennedy was
assassinated I remember coming home from
school and my mother's watching the TV
and tears are streaming up she's
watching the
funeral and when they pass apart where
little John Jr saluting the casket oh my
mother just um you know when your mom
send hysterics and your kid what I I
what to do you know my mom's just oh
that little boy what's going to happen
you know and she just so upset by this
and I okay fine go ahead 40 something
years I have John F Kenny Jr on this had
Seinfeld as first guest and John I'm in
the dressing room it didn't strike me
hey John hey thanks for coming on
congratulations good luck with the
magazine it's really good magazine we
talk a little bit you know okay my next
guest is son of the president please
welcome jonath K as he comes around the
curtain I shake his hand I look up the
Monitor and I didn't start to cry but I
almost did because I never thought that
Circle of my mom JFK that those three
but I I actually saw my mom in the
monitor well you know what I mean I just
I just flash took you back to that
moment well yeah it just took me right
back to that and it was like a just an
interesting moment yeah you lost both
your parents within the space of a year
I think they very soon after each other
what do you feel you owe your parents my
mother to the day she died never
understood I remember my mother telling
my aunt nety what I did for Living Well
Jay has a little skit that he puts on
from town to town like a you know like I
I do a little
dance it just always made me laugh I
remember I called my mom and said he M
I'm on the cover of Time Magazine oh
which one Time Magazine you know time oh
oh yeah I know that yeah Time Magazine M
oh that's good you're on the cover okay
I'll pick that up I said well list call
Uncle Frank in Florida call in and F in
New Jersey and you know and so and so on
can I get tell them remember po she goes
well I mean I think they put you on the
cover the ones they sell around here CU
they know you're from this area she goes
I don't think you're on the I go M I'm
on the cover everywhere she goes I don't
think so I no M I'm on the cover
everywhere I mean my mother could never
get over happy and when they would get
recognized you
know my mother go to so Leno are you oh
did you go to school with my son how you
no no ma m I'm on TV MA that's good
that's only yeah yeah it just yeah no
they what was your dad like my my dad
was the same thing do you get your humor
from them do you think yeah they were
pretty funny you know my dad was an
insurance salesman my dad was a priz
fighter and he sold insurance and they
made him manager and once a month my dad
would put on a show to ins Inspire them
it was all men selling Insurance in
those days it was door too so he would
say you guys you guys can't sell
insurance I can't juggle by the end of
the month I'm going to know how to
juggle you know so he would practice and
the end of the month you throw eggs and
the eggs would hit him in the face and
they would laugh you know you and he
would just do things like that but my
dad was a great role model so he started
selling insurance and he went into his
boss he said what's your hardest
district and they said Harlem so my dad
started selling nickel policies in
Harlem and he made it a pretty
successful area and he he he kind of
turned it around and when he died I got
a letter from a lady who I guess at this
time was in her 80s and '90s and she
said when she was a little girl there
was a Mr Angelo used to come to her
house uh to collect the nickel policy
and always had a tritsie roll or a
lollipop for her and he was the first
white man ever to have dinner in their
apartment and she said when she grew up
she
hoped she'd meet a lot of Italian people
and hope they would be nice like Mr
Angelo and that's when my you realize
one person can really make a difference
you know and just not my dad wasn't a
civil rights and all but he just
believed every but he sold he was in
this area and he got to know his his
people that's what I mean when my dad
was proud when Italians would be on the
because you know with the go that's made
you quite emotional yeah I I do get
emotional about that because it it
really it really struck me that my dad
was not a well educated guy he was smart
but he knew the difference between right
and wrong and
you it's very moving to see how moved
you are yeah it was really really
something for me cuz that was a leading
by example yes you know that's what my
dad always did we're in a garage full of
spectacular wonderful cars you were in
here I think a year or so ago when you
had a horrific accident and it could
have been even worse tell me what
happened I was in the shop and I got a
face full of gas and a SP what was the
car you were working in uh 1907 White
Steam car and my face car were you
underneath it or I was underneath the
gas hit me in the face and then a spark
jumped yeah and you and you were
literally on fire oh yeah I was on fire
and I said Dave I'm on fire he said what
and he pulled me out and jumped on Top's
one of the guys that works in your yeah
I drove to the
hospital and uh I got to the hospital
and they said okay what check you and I
go well I got to go home and get my wife
first I said oh no you can't go me I
said no I'll go look guys I'll come back
in the morning so so I go home and I go
to sleep how did you get home you drove
I drove yeah you drove yourself I drove
myself but I went may your face has been
on fire yeah my face on fire fire then I
went to bed and then I woke up the
pillow had melted to my face my God so
I'm sitting there with scissors cutting
the pillow oh my God some I back to the
hospital they took the pillow off my
face you lost layers of skin didn't you
from oh yeah yeah it was yeah you've got
a broadly a new ear yeah that's a brand
new ear that's pretty good is it how
much of it is actually called ears are
like paper they go up they when you fire
they just because there's no boner in
did you literally lose an it well like
they they re they remag they made that
one did you worry in the perod you in
hos I'm not a worrier I'm not a stress
guy you know anything after the
tonight's show is gravy it's really you
know my parents got to see me be
successful that was one of the great
joys of my life that they were proud of
me and all that kind of stuff when you
had the the fireball injury right the
phone goes and it's the president of the
United States Joe Biden right well
that's what's hilarious okay
because prior to that I my friend Steve
were in his
car and it's on the speaker and now
normally when you could get a call from
the president it it it it's is this
General yes it is are you prepared to
take a call from the president United
States yes I am please stay on the line
so he stay on the line for a
minute President Bush will pick up the
line Jay oh how are you s that's from
the car how you ring hello Jay Jay it's
Joe what Joe Joe Biden I don't oh Joe
Biden president of the United States he
goes yeah how how you feeling I'm I'm
okay sir thank you for calling no no I
just just just made me laugh Jay it's
Joe it just it just made me laugh the
national inquir front page I think was
TVJ in Fireball horror or something oh
yeah Fireball horror but I think most
people believe if they had an extra
$50,000 they would would have no
problems at all and I think people
really most people believe that I think
if you're a happy person and you're s
wealthy well you're happier but if
you're a terrible person you're not
going to be happy because you're still a
terrible person there not the amount I
you've interviewed so many very rich
people yes do you see evidence that
money buys happiness well it doesn't buy
happiness but it could certainly make
you happier I mean it removes worries it
remov also in a way creates others right
yeah but you can I mean the fact that I
could give scholarships to people or put
a roof on my uncle Louis's house so when
I get home Jay gets the big meatball the
big meatballs for Jay he put the roof on
Jay get the big me I get oh I get the
big meatball you know you know so I mean
and that kind of stuff it's it's great
fun yeah how important has Mavis been to
you wonderful me to again been married
44 years yeah that's another where low
self-esteem is a huge thing
because if this woman wouldn't sleep
with me when I was 25 why would they
sleep with me when I'm 65 no I I'm I'm
very fortunate I did not fall I have a
very good woman and you know I try
what's the secret of of longevity do you
think in I think that you know I
remember telling this to uh Drew bore I
said marry your conscience find somebody
who's the person you wish you could be
my wife does a lot of charity work and I
said oh I'm kind of selfish I collect
cars and you know so so I'm going to
marry somebody who's a little better
than I am and and it it it keeps
everything ACH yeah you never had kidss
would you have lik to have done likeing
back no we just never had kids it's just
never you know something the 44 years
went by in a heartbeat you know I like
the idea if I had a gig she could go
with me do you think you'll ever stop
working well if I have a stroke or
something I suppose but only only if you
were incapacitated well I mean I like
you would voluntarily stop you still
love the oh yeah thrill of getting a
laugh is that really what you're about
oh yeah I think that's the most that's
the most fun thing of the world really I
mean because just it it's why I travel
alone when you travel alone this is what
happens you get famous and then you have
people that do things for you you know I
was telling the story about I have a
place in Rhode Island so I go to Rhode
Island and I always go to Joe's Pizza
okay soone some one day guy say hey it's
new place Nicholas Pizza opened up and
oh I'll try it so okay I get there and
there's a line something line I gu Jay
it's Joe what Joe's Pizza Hey Joe how
you doing goes what are you doing here
he goes something wrong with our pizza I
go no no it's it's fine he goes what are
you doing here I said I so I just make
up a lie I go what you know I had a
coupon I figured I'm going I'm going to
try it you know see he goes coupon we
all agreed not to use coupon he's using
coupon okay now now now I'm in this now
I'm in this lie I'm going well um yeah I
don't actually I don't have the C no you
said he well no I'm going to go talk to
him don't talk to him okay now I'm in
this stupid line and it just made me
laugh cuz if I had somebody getting my
pizza for me that wouldn't have happened
you know the same thing happened you do
you not have an Entourage at all no I
don't I had no manager I did a I did a
gig for McDonald's you know corporate
event so they gave me like a stack of of
uh of Happy Meal coupons I go okay now I
don't like to waste money or throw
things so all right I'll eat lunch at
McDonald's and tell you like War Buffett
yeah yeah so I'm in this I'm in this
fancy car that Mercedes SLR where the
doors come up this way so I pull in G
say can I get two Happy Meals the girl
says okay sir we only allow one happy
meal per visit I said well that's fine
he goes no no but I know it's you I can
let me talk to the m no don't talk to no
just just wait could you pull up call up
so s pull up right so then the door
opens right so kids come over and the
manager Miss L normally we have a policy
then I hear a kid go it's j Longo he's
arguing about his Happy Meal coupon I'm
not arguing about my Happy Meal coupon
I'm just I look in this half a million
dollar car I just like an idiot like
fighting with a a 16-year-old kid in MDS
about a Happy Meal it just it just made
me laugh gu goes I I'll give you two
Happy Meal coupons this time but
normally I go yeah I'm okay I'm fine I
gu you know it just it just hilarious
well I mean that's what I mean that's
that's what's fun about being on the
road just just odd things
happen talk TV on TV on radio online and
on your smart
speaking criminals to using XL Bully
dogs as weapons to threaten other no
matter how well trained most dog owners
will tell you a dog can turn you know
what I love about sport today we do it
all sunak sella
scun I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Tor love a scrap you
can almost see this coming around the
tracks with sella bravman she's heading
up one side and richy soon at the
other sakir starma is about to help make
children even taller
now that's what's going to happen if you
vote
labor Long Live JK Rowling and her right
to stand up for women we can only pity
those you despise their straightforward
Politics as somehow
dangerous the amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £40
million so far so40 million so far
results nil absolutely nil Kevin O
Sullivan is the worst presenter on talk
TV sitting on his fat talk for
AIT like brought to you by S KH the
mayor of London ought us with our own
money the the mayor's fireworks rarely
meet anybody that says you know the
thing about London is he got a great
mayor it's a deep charm brilliant
Guy this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this was important after
watching a Tom Cruz film stop creating
all of these funny little factions with
their funny little names the new
conservatives the ERG the common sense
research group the red wool red trouser
popcorn I mean popcorn what what is that
I just cannot see if Richie suak goes
does what David Frost what Lord Frost
wants him to do and go further to the
right on taxes and immigration that that
would turn around the what's predicted
by this poll in a landslide Donald Trump
didn't just win he obliterated this is a
guy facing nearly a 100 criminal charges
and yet all that's done is actually Mak
him more popular Trump is canny enough
to know that all publicity is good
publicity I don't want a president who's
been impeached if he's able to bamboozle
you that's the way it goes with did my 6
months I came came back nobody would
touch me I put my head down and
persisted and carried on when I say I am
God I'm not joking did you feel Elvis
was controlling I've been answering your
question you answer mine it's actually
not my job to answer your questions I've
asked you two questions should a mass
stay in power and are their terror group
you're refusing to answer either of them
that is very telling talk TV is the only
place where you get the truth you've
done a book on poetry poetry and music
for the many I love poetry we can agree
on
that
[Music]
so J I don't even know where to start in
your in your car Emporium but as we as
we head into this room for example uh
past a sea of Bugattis but what are we
looking at here well these are American
cars from the 20s dusenberg BS uh
Packard a little bit of everything where
do you find them where do you Source
your cars well you know if you're into
something it's always other people that
are interested in it too you know odd a
lot of these guys are hermit kind of
guys and they they they've had a car
since it was new and they've kept their
whole life and a lot of them just wanted
to go to a good home you know so I
usually pay what are we looking at here
okay well that was interesting that's
the last dusenberg made by the dusenberg
brothers and the guy I bought it from
bought it in 46 locked it in his garage
and I bought it in 2005 after he passed
away it the garage hadn't been opened in
like 60 years really this has caught my
eye mainly because it's the book of the
mor book of the Morgan yeah so one of
these are Morgan these are Morgan
these're Morgans these two are Morgans
yeah magnificent aesthetic cars well
English cars yeah I'm got to ask you Jo
I mean you come across as so easy
mannered did you ever like lose your
um well you know one time I
actually this kind of like a road rage
Story one day I'm in I'm in my car and
I'm in an old car I'm kind of going
along so guy behind me beep beep beep
beep and I go what I go go around me go
around me so I kind of pull out as he
passes to me he gives me the finger you
know like what's that all about he go f
you you know and I pull up what's F you
and I go let me guess what you go 52 fat
bald huh divorce let me guess your kids
hate you right you hate your job when
was your greatest day was it high school
and I'm just berating the guy and then
he starts crying and I go look I'm sorry
no you're right you're right my but my
kids hate me I don't I said I pull over
pull over so I get in his car I go look
I'm sorry I go no everything you said
was true I said well how old are your
kids he goes 9 and 11 I got two girls
and they don't they hate me I go look do
they like Taylor Swift he goes I love
Taylor Swift I go well look I got on the
show Wednesday i' say why don't you come
Wednesday bring your two kids is my
guess okay I go in the dresser I tell
Taylor about this the greatest gives
them CDs swag talking to the girls like
you what songs you like she couldn't
have been nicer just the most wonderful
person yeah she was really very kind you
know say a little about Taylor Swift
that story as well well yeah what what
do you make of the fact she's now this
billionaire I think it's wonderful I
mean breaking all records beating
Michael Jackson all yeah I think it's
wonderful I think it's great she's she's
deserves everything and you know she's a
really nice person yes I've met her once
I thought she was lovely you know you
don't get any sort of uh attitude or any
no just just a wonderful person don't
tell me you drive that out no I drive
that in La yeah but see it's got tires
not tread see like in Beverly Hills you
use a 30 caliber when you go down wait
wa a second take go downtown you put the
50 Cali you don't drive that through
Beverly Hills I drive it and you know
something people just get out of the way
do the police stop you or no it's street
legal it's no it's it's no bigger than a
Porche I mean it weighs 4 tons and it's
got guns on it but other than that it's
fine now what are you driving uh well
I'm going to take you to my little
vehicle in a moment all right uh you'll
be un surprised to hear it's it's rather
like its owner it's British and classy
oh all right
yeah that's the McLaren F1 that's this
one here yeah that's considered probably
about the most valuable car in the world
you can buy right about now what what
are these worth you know I paid 800,000
for it 98 and people thought it was
crazy but the last offer I got was 20
mil so what oh yeah that's a one just
sold for 24 million yeah $20 million
they only they only Built 64 of them so
in the world yeah and you sit in the sit
in the center yeah but if that car alone
is worth $20 million how many have you
got in total there 206 on the road cars
yeah yeah so I'm doing the math here
there's a lot of well they're not all
worth 20 no no they're not but a lot
them are worth a lot of money right yeah
yeah you like Tesla's wonderful car yeah
you Elon Musk is a genius yes genius
yeah you've actually had him you've
interviewed him in here you know
something he's a a lot of geniuses are
dreamers he's a manufacturer I mean he's
an engineer at you he came to he ended
this Garage in 2007 with his prototype
electric Roadster and I oh this is
pretty cool and he says you know Jay I'm
going to
charging stations all up and down the
coast it'll be free and you can pull in
and charge it I'm going yeah right like
that'll happen but he was smart enough
to build the infrastructure at the same
time everybody else who builds an
electric car where can I charge it oh
you can charge anywh just plug it well
no you can't I mean he's the only the
first one to really get the things so no
he he's a genius incredible yeah very
bright guy so you've got all your cars
the Aston Martin raped that's a rede
yeah that's based on the laganda raped
are you thinking James Bond when you
look at this little beauty you know if I
do a little Daniel Craig or maybe
probably connory actually huh what do
you think I was thinking more Terry
Thomas but yeah
yeah well look you can have it 20
million all right there you go thank you
thank you very much it's my it's my
going right obviously not worth that but
because I've driven it right cuz You'
driven it massively increases the value
no that is the
Val J it's been what a what a pleasure
pleasure
we're here thanks for joining us you're
with talk TV on TV on radio online on
your smart speaker as well they have
made a statement condemning Hamas we
expect to see the crown revisit Harry's
anti-semitic Halloween costume criminals
to using XL Bully dogs as weapons to
threaten others no matter how well
trained most dog owners will tell you a
dog can turn you know what I love about
toour today we do it all sunak sella
guns I rather like David Cameron I don't
sort of bear him any ill will because he
delivered the referendum that he said he
would deliver the Israelis are very
conciliatory all they want is to be
recognized the timing of this hamus
attack comes because there was the
expectation there was going to be a deal
down to normalizing relations with Saudi
Arabia the Tories love a scrap you can
almost see this coming around the tracks
with sella bravman she's heading up one
side and richy soon at the other
reshuffles usually very dull this one
had booster rockets at attached to it
certainly the tone has shifted in terms
of what Rashi sunak has done the
question now is what he does next the
police appr Pro Palestine that is just
not right you swear an o in the police
to act without fear or favor the co
inquiry seems to have turned into a sort
of panine there's not really any
substance to it it's hard to know
whether it's a fce or a tragedy talk TV
has spoken exclusively to a member of
the Blade Runners do you have a message
for sadik Khan we're not stopping until
you
stop the IM amount of time it's taken
the number of illegal migrants currently
sent by us to Rwanda zil the amount of
money it's cost we're saying what are we
saying it's cost about 140 million £140
million so far so40 million so far
result nil absolutely nil are we only
going to be trusting sources like meta
and Google where is our unbiased news
going to come from Kell in winter is
cold that is from the Jeremy Corbin book
Kevin Sullivan is the worst presenter on
talk TV sitting on his fat ass talking
liit if you're walking towards me and
you're a vegan she have a great big
orange sticker over here saying watch
out vegan's
about the weirdest plank that we've had
in three years hundreds and hundreds of
mice in a box which he walks into a
branch of McDonald MC mous man MC mous
man MC mous man he should be easy enough
to catch this guy shouldn't he I mean
he's got house full of
mice this is a major Summit President
Biden decided this is important after
watching a Tom Cruz film